[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILLIP COLETTI: Hello everyone.
Welcome to CST 201, Establishing
Financial Governance on GCP.
I'm Phillip Coletti.
I'm a product manager on
the Cloud billing team,
and I work on cost
management features.
Today with me co-presenting
is Aurelie Fonteny.
And she's a product manager
on Quota, also for GCP.
And it is 3:30, so we're
getting to the end of the day.
Try to bear with us, then
we can all go grab a beer,
have a little bit of fun after.
The first thing I want to do
is make a quick public service
announcement.
We're going to save some
time at the end for Q&A. This
is probably old
hat by now, but we
have a Dory Q&A
tool which you can
find inside your NEXT
app for this session.
If you have questions as we
go through the presentation,
just add them in there or upvote
the ones you're interested in,
and we'll try to get to them
at the end of the session.
Awesome.
So the first thing I
actually want to do
is get a quick sense for
who's in the audience today.
This will be my interactive
portion of the presentation.
Let's start off
with an easy one.
Raise your hand if you've made
the switch to public cloud
already.
OK, that's most of the
audience, maybe like 80%.
For the rest of you, maybe you
haven't made the switch yet,
but you're still considering.
That's cool too.
Put your hands back
up if you've ever
experienced a surprise
on your cloud bill,
either GCP or any of your
other cloud providers.
OK, it's a higher percentage
than makes me happy,
but not surprising.
All right, a trickier
one, raise your hand
if you feel confident
in your ability
to monitor costs in the cloud--
a much smaller number.
How about if you feel
confident in your ability
to control your costs in the
cloud, so to actually put
guardrails in place
to protect yourself.
I got one hand in the back.
Thank you, sir.
So we're going to
talk about that today.
Hopefully we'll have
a few more hands
up on those questions
by the end of the day.
What we're to talk about.
What is financial governance?
Kind of this abstract concept.
We'll make it a
little more concrete.
We'll talk about
why it's important,
and how you can go about doing
this on GCP with our tools.
Some of you might work
for larger companies
where tinkering around in
the console across a thousand
projects doesn't
really scale well.
So we'll talk about how to
do this at scale using APIs.
And we'll also
sprinkle in some demos
throughout the presentation.
We have roughly ordered them in
terms of increasing coolness.
So stick around to
the end because we're
saving best for last.
And I'm going to
start with an anecdote
about the opportunities
and challenges of cloud
and what this means for
financial governance.
So let's suspend
disbelief and pretend
we all work for Acme Company.
Here is a cartoonish
view of what our resource
consumption might look like.
We're a growing business,
so our costs are
trending up and to the right.
And we have these
seasonal fluctuations
as our business demands change
and contrast over the course
of a year or a month.
Now, back when we ran
our own data center,
we had to procure
hardware ahead of time.
We had to provision
for the peak.
We had to forecast our
demand ahead of time.
And that's represented by
this dotted green line.
And we don't have a lot of
contrast in terms of color
here, but I'll talk
through it anyway.
Sometimes we
under-provisioned, right?
And we can't serve all
our customer demand.
You can see our
dotted green line
is underneath our
blue demand line.
And then we have a degraded
end consumer experience--
slow page load times,
unresponsive applications,
all bad news.
Maybe we're even able to
keep our core workloads up,
but we have to restrict our
developers discretionary use.
And that slows our time
to market, also bad news.
Alternatively, other
times we over-provision,
and now we have all of this
wasted resources that are just
sitting idle because
we over-provisioned,
and we have too many servers.
So we have a bunch of wasted
costs, still bad news.
Fast forward to today, we've
moved on to public cloud,
and now we're able to capture
all these savings because we
don't have to provision
ahead of time,
we don't have the
bridge in for the peak,
we have no more long
procurement lead times,
and we have no more
wasted capacity like this.
So this is the benefit
of cloud, right?
We just pay for what we need.
And now when we have that
unexpected spike in demand,
we can scale up because of
the elasticity of cloud.
So that shaded yellow
area represents
something we wouldn't have
been able to do before
if we hadn't procured for it.
But the flexibility
that we get with Cloud
comes with a new challenge,
which is all of a sudden
we can serve demand
that maybe wasn't
as important for our business.
Back with our data center,
our costs were literally
bounded by the physical
servers we bought and put there
and the software
licenses we run on them.
But now we can generate costs
from anything that happens.
One of my engineering
teams could
spin up a large-scale
testing environment
and forget to turn it back off.
Or a business analyst
on my team might
write a bad query that performs
a join on a really, really
big data set and incurs a
commensurately large BigQuery
build.
Raise your hand if you've
seen one of these two things
or something of the like?
Yeah, we've got some hands up.
I tend to write queries
brute force trial and error,
so I have personally had
experience with the second one.
So that brings us to the
point of the session today.
We're going to talk about how to
get back in the driver's seat.
Financial governance is
all about making a plan
and sticking to it.
It's about avoiding
surprises on your bill.
It's about giving you the
flexibility to scale to meet
the demands of your business
where you want to, where it
adds value, and the control
to restrict resources where it
doesn't.
So I'm going to read this quote.
It comes from a Gartner study.
I think it sums up the
situation pretty well.
"90% the respondents--"
to their survey--
"agree that public
cloud will save money
for their organizations.
However, few companies
have implemented
financial management
processes for public cloud.
Therefore, few have
any idea whether they
are achieving their goals."
Think about that.
It is pretty clear that
there is a massive disconnect
between what many of us know
is important for our business
and our ability to actually
go achieve those goals.
So, let's get back
in the driver's seat.
We're going to do that in three
kind of simple steps today.
We need to plan to make sure
we know what our costs are
expected to be moving forwards.
We're going to monitor our
costs against that plan,
triage alerts, notify people who
might want to go take action.
And then we're going to
actually go control our costs,
put guardrails in place
to protect ourselves
from unexpected expense.
First up is planning.
It's the essential first step.
And the way that
we're going to do this
varies a lot depending on what
our organization looks like,
what our processes are.
So I'm not going to go
into too much detail
on this particular step.
But I am going to go over
some of the tools that
make this easier on GCP.
So here I have a screenshot
from our Billing Reports tool.
You can find this in
the Billing console.
And this is a fairly
simple dashboarding UI
that allows you to view your
historical cost trends on GCP.
This is actually an example
from a large internal customer.
And you can see some
simple things here.
Our costs are overall growing.
And then about halfway
through the chart,
you'll see that
there's this inflection
point where the chart--
the cost started
to grow a lot more.
And this actually happened
because they launched
a new feature that
went viral with users,
and all of a sudden,
their costs started
to grow with that new feature.
And we can look at that new
trend, forecast it forwards,
and see if business
continues as usual, what
are my costs going to look like
over the next month, quarter,
year?
If I wanted to go into a
little bit more detail,
I could use the Billing Export.
We'll pipe your
data into BigQuery
with a lot more granularity
so you can look at this
and slice it by region,
or label, or even
things like machine
shape, get down
to a really fine level
of detail if it's
important for my
planning processes.
And once I've accounted
for my organic growth,
there is some things
that Google's just not
going to know about.
Like let's say I'm going to
launch a new application,
and I expect it to have 100
daily actives with x footprint
of storage and compute needs,
I can make that capacity plan,
but Google has no way of
knowing about it ahead of time.
Or maybe I'm going to
launch into Europe and Asia
for the first time,
and I need to spin up
new instances of my services
in those new regions.
Once I have that capacity
plan, the Google Cloud Platform
pricing calculator will help me
turn that into a financial cost
analysis that I
can then build into
my forward-looking forecast.
But stepping back from
tooling for a sec,
regardless of whether you use
GCP tooling, or spreadsheets,
or some sort of
third-party software,
just remember to make
cloud financial governance
part of your financial
planning process,
and whatever your
regular cadence is,
monthly, quarterly,
annual, et cetera.
So, now that we have a
well-reasoned financial plan,
let's actually get to
the interesting part.
We need to put in place
some monitoring so
that we know when we're getting
off track from that plan.
So at this point, I'm
tired of looking at slides.
I hope you're tired
of looking at slides.
Let's actually hop into
the console and start
doing some demos.
Awesome.
So this is the
Budgets and Alerts
UI in the Billing Console.
This is the core toolkit
that GCP provides you
for monitoring your spend.
And how it works is this.
You'll create a budget
once for the scope
of spend that you care about.
Let's say, it's an
application or a project.
And then Google will, behind the
scenes, monitor costs for you
against that budget
into perpetuity
and let you know if you're
getting off track from what
you think is reasonable.
So for the purposes
of this demo,
let's say that at
Acme Company, we're
launching a new application,
and we're calling it
the Amazing Application.
We think we know how many
users are going to be on it.
We think we know that it's going
to cost about $1,000 per month.
So now we'll create a
budget to monitor that.
I'll name it the Amazing
Application Budget.
Excellent.
I think I've been frozen
a little too long.
OK, there we go.
I'm going to set it to monitor
Phil's Amazing Application
because I just want it to look
after this one application.
I don't want to dilute it
with the spend from all
of the other projects
that I have running.
And again, I'm going to give it
a budget of $1,000 per month.
So after I figure out and
lock in how much I think
I'm going to spend
for this application,
then I get to go set my
alert threshold rules.
And this defines the
notification behavior
that I want Google to follow.
By default, we're
going to alert you
when you cross 50%, 90%, and
100% of that budget amount.
So when the amazing
application spends $500,
we're going to send you
your first notification.
But in this case, let's say
I don't actually want that.
I want it to be a little more
like my cell phone data usage
plan, so I just want
to know when I'm
about to go over the budget.
So I'll just keep 90% and 100%.
And I'm actually going to add
one more alert notification.
And instead of triggering
on actual spend,
I'm going to trigger
on forecasted spend.
And I'm going to
set that to 110%.
So what that means
is if I'm forecasted
to go above my
budget amount, even
if it's early in the
month, then I'm going
to get an alert notification.
So in this case,
let's say I'm spending
way more than expected,
pretty early on
we're going to let you know
that you're off track to miss
your budget, even
if it's only, say,
the third day of the month.
Now I hit Save, I lock
that in as a budget,
and you can see that here we
now have the Amazing Application
Budget.
It's configured.
We've spent about $364 of our
$1,000 budget for the month,
so we're maybe roughly on track.
I don't want to wait for us to
get really close to the budget,
so I'm actually just going to
cut over back to the slides
and show you what an alert
notification would look like.
So let's imagine the Amazing
Application goes viral,
and we have way more
users than expected.
All of a sudden, I get this
alert notification in my inbox.
It says, you are forecasted
to spend more than 110%
of your budget.
In this case, it was
for the month of March
because that was last month.
So now I have this
information, and I
can go do something with it.
I can have a conversation
with my engineering team.
Maybe our users
are adopting faster
than expected-- good news.
I probably don't want to
take any major action.
Maybe I'll just
increase the budget
so I don't get this
notification in the future.
But maybe our user growth
is not as fast as expected,
and then I want to take
some other sort of action,
which brings us to control.
So far, all we've talked about
is monitoring and planning.
But we actually want
to take some action
to make sure that our
costs don't go over
budget in the first place.
And the first thing we can do is
kind of what I just described.
We get an alert and
signal, and we have
to decide what to do with it.
We triage that with
the engineering team,
we decide maybe we have some
over provisioned virtual
machines, and we can
go downsize those
so that we save some money.
Maybe our storage is growing
faster than expected,
and we want to migrate
some of those objects
over to cold line storage.
We have some other tools
at our disposal as well.
Quota is a tool that allows
us to throttle our resource
consumption so that
we actually rate limit
how much our spending can
increase moving forwards.
And I'll let Aurelie talk more
about that a little bit later
in the presentation.
Kind of the last biggest
hammer in our arsenal
is to actually remove
billing from a project.
So we can take a
project, disable billing.
And what that will
effectively do
is stop all costs
from being accrued,
but it will also immediately
disable and delete
all resources and workloads that
are running in that project.
So it's kind of an
irrevocable decision.
And it might be fitting in a
very discretionary dev project
where the consequences
of deleting stuff
are not a big deal,
and where people
might be making more
careless mistakes,
and where it's just like
an easy decision to make,
so I'll just get
it out of the way.
But for something like a
production environment,
that could be a very
costly decision.
We probably wouldn't
recommend that type of action.
The other thing we can
do is put guardrails
in place proactively.
So never let spending get
out of control to begin with.
And there's two levers that
we have at our disposal.
One is resource restriction.
Everything I just said
on the previous slide,
we can try to set that up
to happen automatically
before anything ever goes wrong.
For more production-like
environments,
this is where we think about
permission restriction is
a better option because
we don't actually
want to degrade an
end-consumer experience,
but we do want to make sure that
only a few authorized users are
making changes.
For the rest of
the presentation,
though, we're going to
talk a little bit more
about resource restriction
in that dev test environment,
and talk about how to put
automated controls in place
to do this on your behalf.
So the first way
we can do this is
with a last feature of
budgets that I glossed over
in my previous demo called
Programmatic Notifications.
In addition to
sending email alerts,
we can also configure budgets to
send programmatic notifications
to a Pub/Sub channel,
so it will constantly,
every 20 minutes or so,
ping the budget status
to this Pub/Sub channel.
And we can listen to this
Pub/Sub with a Cloud Function
and automate any kind
of logic we want.
So one example would be, let's
say that my dev project hits
my $1,000 monthly budget.
I actually want to go and
stop all virtual machines
from running.
That was the
discretionary budget,
we've used it up, let's
stop spending money.
And then if we need an
override, come talk to me,
we'll re-enable it, or
it just starts back up
at the beginning
of the next month.
Who wants to see me actually
try to do this right now?
I got some hands, yes.
That's the mildly enthusiastic
response I was hoping for.
Awesome.
So I'm going to pop
into a different billing
account, my Budget Demo account,
and create another budget.
I'm going to this one
my next19-budget-demo,
and give it $1,000 budget.
I don't care so much about
the alert email thresholds
this time.
But what I do want to
do that's different
is connect a Pub/Sub topic.
And you can do this down at
the bottom of the Create Budget
screen.
I'm going to set it to monitor--
or to post to the
next19-budget-demo topic,
and I'll save that.
So now I have my
NEXT 19 Budget Demo.
And it's going to send
these budget status alerts
to this Pub/Sub
channel, right here,
the next19-budget-demo
Pub/Sub channel.
You'll notice that I have
one thing subscribing
to this Pub/Sub
channel right now.
And that's a Cloud Function
called gcf budget demo compute
2 next19 budget demo.
It's a long name, but I
wanted it to be descriptive.
And this is that Cloud Function
that's listening to it.
You can find all of this
code in example demos
in our technical documentation,
so don't feel like you
need to copy all this down.
You can definitely
find it online,
but I'm going to walk
you through what it does.
So the first thing
is I'm going to parse
the Pub/Sub payload to get
the relevant information.
Then, if I have not yet passed
the 100% budget threshold,
so if I'm still under
my budget amount,
I'm actually not
going to do anything.
As soon as I pass that
threshold, though,
that's when I start
to take action.
I'm going to authenticate
with the Google Cloud APIs.
I'm going to go get the
list of running instances
from GCE in that project.
I'm going to stop
the instances that
are running in that project.
And then because my
team really hates email,
and they really like
Slack, I'm going
to go post an update into
their Slack channel and say,
hey, I just shut down all
your VMs, just so you know.
Now, I also don't
want to wait around
for the rest of the month
to pass my $1,000 budget,
so we're going to fake
it just for the demo.
And I'm actually just going to
post the same Pub/Sub payload
that our budget service would
send so that we can fast
forward a little bit here.
Let's say I pass
that 90% threshold.
I've spent $900.
When I send this message,
nothing should happen.
And if we go look at
our GCE page, refresh,
all the instances
are still running,
nothing's really happened.
But then all of a sudden, we
cross this 100% threshold.
And when I hit this
button, you should
see a little more fireworks.
Let's go pop over,
check our Slack channel.
You can see, hey, we
have a notification.
The NEXT 19 Budget Demo has
exceeded 100% of the threshold.
We've stopped four
running virtual machines
in the projects.
Sounds good, let's
see if it happened.
And now you can see
the same project,
we've terminated all of the VMs.
So at this point,
if virtual machines
are a big portion
of our project cost,
we've pretty effectively
stopped a lot of the costs
from accruing in that
dev project, which
is exactly what we wanted.
And this all happened behind
the scenes, automated.
Once I set it up, this'll
just happen any month.
If we could just cut back
over to the slides now.
So that's programmatic
notifications.
And again, this is not
necessarily the one action
you want to take.
It's more of a
flexible framework
that you can use to implement
whatever logic makes sense
for you, for your business,
for your consumers
within your organization.
And now to talk
a little bit more
about some of the
other methods you
can use to control your
costs actively on GCP,
I'm going to hand
it over to Aurelie.
AURELIE FONTENY: Thank you.
Thank you, Phillip.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
So we've talked about
various form of controls.
And one of them is Quota.
So if you think about Quota,
you can think about a cell phone
data plan.
And here, your quota would
be the data plan limit
that you set.
So you can set Quota on
a select set of services,
either at runtime, or you can
do it at project creation time.
So, for example, say you're
starting out with BigQuery,
and you expect a cost of about
$100 per day on BigQuery.
So now you know that if
your query usage reaches
like a cost of around
$1,000 per day,
then something
weird is going on.
So you can set a quota
to provide guardrails
so it doesn't happen.
And once you've set a quota, you
can also create a quota alert
to notify you just before
you hit that quota limit
so that you can set back
the quota quickly in case
the use is actually legitimate.
So we're going to go
ahead and also do a demo.
So let me go ahead and--
great.
So here, we're
going to illustrate
what we've just talked about.
So as you can see here, I'm
in a cloud console for Quota,
and I've selected
the service BigQuery.
And we have a
query usage per day
that's unlimited by
default. Now what
I'm going to do is I'm
going to go ahead and set it
to one terabyte.
So I'm getting a
message to confirm
that I'm OK to reduce the
quota limit by more than 10%.
So I'm going to confirm that.
And as long as the quota that
is being reduced to the limit
that's--
compared to the limit
that's set by the service
producer-- in this
case, it's BigQuery--
should be pretty quick.
So you can see here that it's
been updated to one terabyte.
If we look at our UI, you can
see that it's actually already
been updated.
In reality, it
takes a few minutes
to update our servers globally.
So I have a cookie of this
project where I've already
set the limit to one terabyte.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to show you that
in fact, I won't
be able to run a large query
that's over one terabyte.
So here I have a large query,
and I'm going to click Run.
OK, yeah, I have probably
set the result to be cached.
So now I'm going
to run it again,
but it's not cached this time.
So as you can see,
I get the message
that the quota has been
exceeded for query usage today.
Now, I'm going to go ahead
and run another query.
And this time it's a small
query that's about 100 meg.
So let's just make sure that
I'm not using cache results,
and we are going to run it.
And this time, because
the query is pretty small,
it's under one terabyte, it's
actually running successfully.
So what we've done is
we've just demonstrated
that you can send
guardrails with Quota
on the query usage per
day that you can use.
Now let's go back to the slides.
So we've shown you how you can
set Quota to set guardrails
on one project.
We've shown you how we can set
a budget on one project also
using the UI.
Now what if you had tens
of projects where you need
to set quota and budget alerts?
In that case, going to the
UI is no longer an option.
So this is where you can
use APIs to programmatically
and grammatically manage
budgets and quotas.
So we have two APIs
here that are relevant.
The first one is the budget API,
and it's coming to Alpha soon.
And it will allow you to
create and manage budgets
with the same nobs that you're
used to today in the UI.
The second one here is
the Service Usage API.
It's already in
Alpha today, and it
allows you to
modify Quota as long
as it is below the
default that is
set by the service producers.
So then what you can do is you
can use your own tooling, so
your own scripts, or use
deployment management tool
to go ahead and create budgets
and Quota guardrails at project
creation time.
So let's go ahead,
and we're going
to do a demo now
to just illustrate
what we just talked about.
And we are going to do it
using a Service Usage API.
And what we're going to
do is every time we create
a new project, we're going to
put basic guardrails in place
to control our
BigQuery analysis cost.
So we will create
a default policy
to limit the BigQuery analysis
to $1,000 per day, which
equates to 200 terabytes
in this case in terms
of query usage per day.
So as you can see here, we
are first creating a project.
And then we are granting an
existing service account--
is it here?
Yeah.
We are granting an existing
service account called
su-quota, the service
usage admin role,
so it can actually change the
quota on the target project.
And then the last step is to set
the BigQuery daily quota to 200
terabytes instead of unlimited.
So you can see here
that I'm setting
the quota to 200 terabytes.
And this is the quota that
we are actually setting.
So now I'm going to cut over
to the demo, which is basically
reusing the script.
So you can see I'm
creating a project,
I'm granting a service account,
the service usage admin role.
I am setting the BigQuery
daily quota to 100 terabytes.
And so I'm going to create
a project called CST Dev01.
And right now, it's creating it.
And now, I'm going to grant
the role to the service usage--
the service usage admin role.
You can see that.
And then I'm going to set
the quota to 200 terabytes.
So now let's go
ahead and take a look
at our newly created project.
So this is the project
we've just created.
And here we are looking at
the Cloud Console for Quota.
And if we are looking at
the query usage per day,
it's been set to 200 terabytes--
oh no, 20 terabytes actually.
I guess I didn't change it.
It's 20 terabytes.
So that-- let me see.
Whoops.
Yeah, you can see actually
it was 20 terabytes, not 200.
Anyway, so what
I've just shown you
is how to programmatically set
the quota at project creation.
And now this basically
concludes the presentation.
So I'm going to go and recap
what we've talked about.
So we've talked about what
financial governance is
and why it's important.
We've talked about how do to
establish financial governance
using cost management tools.
And in particular, those
cost management tools
are budget, and the
associated alert notification
for monitoring cost.
And for reactive
control, you can
use a service-specific
cloud consoles and APIs.
And to proactively
control your costs,
you can use programmatic
budget notifications
in conjunction with
the Cloud Functions.
And you can also use Quota
to put in some guardrails.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]